yeah we can definitely check out the
horses are out now we're gonna have
three games of this so don't worry we'll
get to break down this content for you
yep maybe let Johnny Cash's inspired the
Ring of Fire you know what I mean it all
comes out now we're gonna see it going
on but yet this is the horse gameplay
that we were looking for again though
you're not gonna get away with you can't
just charge at two people and hope for
the best you will be taken down and look
at the horse may have survived up with a
rider certainly didn't well yeah that's
an interesting point actually it's the
horse is very similar to other sort of
open vehicles where you can die but your
vehicle or horse in this case may
survive because the horse has a higher
health level than you do it's one thing
to even it up it's another to keep it
and then you know turn it to an
advantage it's not easy to do you have
to weather the storm not just once but
the reinforcements when they come
through take down these squads back to
back in the horse mounting was awesome
that was a girly animation that was
really cool I was just like I haven't
got time to sort of get on it properly
so I'm just gonna jump on it and I'm not
loving the diversity of weapon weapon
ruining so far already you've seen the
shotgun coming through clearing out that
close range we're in that infantry sort
of area where they reflect upon the song
rumble with Cena's this is not brought
month I can tell you that right now so
you gotta get into the battlefield and
do some work so he's gonna be going for
it going with the charge here but you
can see the punish come out from the
others reseller very well there's George
us rifles gonna Nick the horse and go
for a ride why know for it dr. Grubbs
you may as well take it if you can
unfortunately didn't manage to get away
there but no that was a valiant effort I
think he deserves some credit they're
always going for the anti-tank light on
the horse that was an interesting way to
try and take that one down and so far
the horses look really good here they
look like they work with the map they
don't seem to be clunky or just out of
place they seem to be really having a
purpose however the riders on the other
hand of being garnished the plane
crashes this environment is absolutely
beautiful yeah you've got the bullets
that you fired do actually travel across
the map they take time to reach the
enemy that you're firing at you've got
bullet drop and pull it drag as well
people who don't know what bullet drag
is that's where oh look at that for a
roadkill that was fantastic that was
actually either a really good bit of
skill or something extremely lucky by
the way it was a cool bit of footage no
not just kill one shot one kill all
right that's what I cling to and I will
always stick to that you know I be a
naysayer or I'll have to bring up the
horse puns okay